it's the weekend and it's this country
Stern the people have been calling the
measures that have been announced
quarantine all kinds of places from
restaurants to gyms are shut down but
there's been no formal ban on people
leaving their homes unless they're over
65 years old the weather is beautiful
it's a fantastic weekend and usually all
the people would be out well that's why
I want to check out a few locations and
see what's going on and give these
places a quarantine commitment score
[Music]
so I start my tour around Moscow's most
popular spots with remember the Scorpion
song alright follow the Moskva down to
Gorky Park that's right
[Music]
gorky park here it is officially it is
shut down but there are a couple of
beautiful promenade right outside it and
I can tell you that I only see two
people here so I'll give it 9 out of 10
for its location quarantine commitment
score
[Music]
Moscoe there's a cool new place for
selfies with the Kremlin in the
background it's called the soaring
bridge we're approaching it right now
you can see it over there
[Music]
and it's completely deserted no access
and I've been told that technically it's
part of a park that's also closed so
like I said access restricted no people
ten out of ten
[Music]
we are on nikolskoe street this place
was a magnet for football fans from all
over the planet during the World Cup
2018 it literally felt like a tin of
sardines in here
[Applause]
[Music]
well at this point as you can see I
wouldn't say that I've only encountered
one or two passers-by the restaurants
are closed but there you have it
so probably I'd say five out of ten
[Music]
we're at a place called the Depot food
mall which is a combination of a food
market and a food court this hip complex
it's also full of fancy bars and even
nightclubs and I'm so not used to seeing
this place almost completely empty
actually I was sure that I'd see some
hipsters just trying to hang around here
even outside it turns out that the food
part is actually operating because it
counts as groceries but other than that
everything shut down and I don't see
anyone here pretty much so just for the
public's responsibility I guess this
place gets ten out of ten but of course
I guess it's a bit of a hard time for
the market traders
you